[Music]
so when you're flying an airplane
there's a bunch going on all at once as
a pilot whenever you fly the people in
the airplane are the most important
thing to you since that's your
responsibility to get them back to the
ground safely and there are always
things that we can't control
I heard of a pilot who got sunscreen in
his eyes and couldn't fly they're just
you know just things that happen and
knowing that we have another tool in the
pilot's toolbox to be able to say I need
help right now and I need to get to the
ground safely that's really exciting I'm
here at garments hangar at the new
century airfield in Kansas where we're
going to test out the company is auto
land system this is the first FAA
certified automatic landing system for
small aircraft and I'm hoping that we'll
get some great footage of us flying in
the sky and also great footage of us
landing safely around my 3 she's cleared
for takeoff just want to auto lending
for planes actually isn't new it's been
employed in commercial aircraft for
decades and in fact there are parts of
Europe where it's absolutely mandatory
because of weather conditions might make
it difficult for pilots to land with
their eyes alone but the existing
systems are big and bulky and often
require there to be equipment on the
ground to help guide the plane to land
safely auto land as we now know it is
designed for the pilot so the pilots in
charge he activates the system and the
aircraft in certain cases certain
airports certain capabilities can do a
hands-off landing garbin autonomy Auto
land empowers the passengers to land an
airplane no one else has enabled a
passenger to control the outcome of
their flight in the event a pilot can't
do that for whatever reason you probably
recognize Garmin by their GPS devices
and smart watches but it's actually been
involved in the aviation industry since
its founding in 1989 I had the
opportunity to fly in two planes that
were owned by Garmin partners and
outfitted with the auto lien software
the software successfully landed the
plane while I was in it and that made me
curious about the challenges of making a
product that can adapt to ever-changing
factors like weather and flight patterns
to lay as successfully 100 percent of
the time
i understanding is at the the utter
landing system that we're here to check
out is part a bigger system of
autonomous products and you talked a
little bit about the other autonomous
features on the aircraft and so we've
got obviously the autopilot emergency
descent which if it it senses that the
pilot might be incapacitated or not
alert it'll automatically descend the
aircraft you'll or altitude the system
can also automatically engage if that
activates and then goes into a level
mode and remains in level mode for
longer than about two minutes on this
aircraft the auto and will engage and
late the pilot and the occupants of the
aircraft down to a landing so one of the
challenges with putting a system like
auto land into an airplane like this is
that it needs to be small and
lightweight and it needs to be
affordable so those are three of the
main things that we've considered as we
were designing this system we wanted to
make sure that the system was something
that was repeatable and certifiable and
additionally we worked with our own
aircraft so we started off up at also to
you doing layers at 5,000 feet above a
runway tested up there and made sure
that everything was working together in
concert and in harmony before we brought
it down to the ground where it was a bit
more high risk that the airplane would
have something happened to it and how
many test flights have you done with the
the auto lean system in an actual plane
hundreds of tests yeah we went the
ticket aircraft several hundred times
doing our lamb because the technology is
so different it took years for Garmin
and its partners to walk through tests
and demonstrate that its system was
successful and safe it's always pilot
centered we don't ever want to hear the
pilot say what's it doing now that can
never be the case so the technologies
that will focus on keep the pilot center
of the loop but we're gonna put safety
nets around them and we're gonna do
things that can help reduce the workload
for the pilot because human error is
still the number one reason for airplane
crashes and I think probably always will
be I mean I've also been asked where do
we think this technology should go I
like to say if it flies this technology
should be on it and that means if it's a
smaller airplane it should be there we
need to find a way to get it there but
likewise I think you should have that
expectation if you get on a commercial
airliner I think you should expect to
know that this type of technology is
there too that if for whatever reason
pilots can't do their job we've got the
safety technology that can step up and
do this I have family members that are
pilots and knowing that if something was
to happen to them even if they're flying
by themselves the airplane can get to
the ground and you know get help for
that person it's really exciting it
really humbling to know that we've
worked on something like that